thank you to the Logan family as always
for sponsoring this lecture series
and thank you to you I want to thank
the people in the audience because even
though they're trying to interrupt the
talk they are showing a lot of Bravery
for even coming into this Auditorium
with such an allegedly genocidal Maniac
I think it's very impressive
hold on what what are you saying I can't
quite make out what you're saying what
is that
oh okay now I got it okay they're saying
trans lives matter okay I think I got it
I think do you have anything else to say
just that okay
[Music]
trans lives matter okay I think I got it
does anyone have a pen so I can write
that down
laughs
oh that's a naughty word you know that's
that's not a word fit for a lady that's
not the way ladies should speak and I
know we're gonna be talking about how
ladies should speak here tonight
all right good night
here we go
[Applause]
all right you know you know it's amazing
how many words do you think that woman
knows maybe seven I by my count
you know what's a what's really amazing
what's really amazing about her and not
not all the rest of them but that that
lady in particular what's incredible is
that she she's
speaking right here in front of a
genocidal Maniac could you imagine the
courage that must take to walk in here
goodness gracious when I found I didn't
know that I was a genocidal Maniac
before this week but I I read about it
in Rolling Stone and The Daily Beast and
the Huffington Post and a few other
newspapers as well and I was I was
caught off guard
uh having never considered committing a
genocide before I wondered if perhaps I
should take on some kind of a
dictatorial name such as maybe Benito
michalini
thought maybe slobodon Michael osovich
or perhaps malcol but but none of them
really seem to fit
the reason being
I'm just not really a genocide kind of
guy you know I'm not listen I'm not
judging I'm just saying for me I am not
particularly inclined toward genocide